We have so
far built multivariate non-parametric
models using kernel density estimation.
We can also ask the question,
are there outliers in the data?
The Mahalanobis distance for a single
variable x, can be defined this way.
Where Mu x is the mean value for x.
And S is the covariance matrix.
We use the inverse of S here
to get this product matrix.
Similarly for two identically
distributed variables x and
y, we take the difference transposed.
And use the inverse of
the covariance matrix and
then the difference and
multiply them together.
In both cases the values
are always positive definite.
Since it's a true distance function.
The Mahalanobis distance gives
us a simple way to look for
outliers in the data.
The square of the Mahalanobis
distance in two dimensions or
with two variables is equal to the
chi-square with two degrees of freedom.
Thus that distance directly give
us how far these values of data
are from their central tendencies
in the probability distributions.
In our case,
we have two distributions of F1 and F2.
F1 was the average Medicare
payment amount and
F2 was the average
Medicare Allowed amount.
We had inspected these
two distributions and
they seemed to be quite
identically distributed.
Assuming they were identically
distributed, given that F1 and
F2 were quite identically distributed.
We had the derived variables x and
x bar identically distributed.
Can we look for outliers in a joint
distribution of x and x bar?
Moreover if we do find outliers
using the Mahalanobis distance
we can still ask the question
what do these outliers mean?
Well, we will leave it up to you
to find what the meaning
of these outliers could be.
Let's go back to the i
Python notebook and
implement the code for
the Mahalanobis distance and
see if we can find some outliers
in our variables x and x bar.